car à milito 45 bal à s'entendre ça y
est vous êtes en scène
[Musique]
excusez vous rêviez mon mari je l'avoué
pour une histoire à prématurée à son
examinateur
antoine moretti je suis une nouvelle
obstétriciens ça vous empêche pendant
que lui dire bonjour je présente antoine
qui vous à l'écart était en santé la
série qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
je suis désolé joyal
1 je veux une vision confondent les
syndicats guyanais tu mets chef dès
qu'ils se réveillent 3 voici on peut
réduire les coûts de refroidissement
4 la dilatation c'est bien on va bientôt
pouvoir lancés à la péridurale qu'elle
péridurale callebaut envoyer des
satellites dans l'espace ça va le sentir
passer son butin croyez moi
max et ma femme qui va accoucher à les
voir avant que j'appelle c'est très bien
pour peur de mourir m'avait la seule
elle a besoin de moi je dessine
quicktime x mois les lits plantés sur un
pic avant même prix que ça sympa tout va
bien cela c'est ok
ould amar ghoul religieux sans quoi la
journée son corps
j'ai dit à ma femme que je serai à ses
côtés si jamais un couche aujourd'hui
j'y serai
ici une rango je vais pas
suite c'est pour ça que je fais ce
métier
c'est que toutes ces femmes puissent
accoucher dans les meilleures conditions
et
[Musique]